what can you see this bad just my look
yeah hi guys our name is Chris ah you do
not know no you don't like it's
different now Father's Day is upon us
which I mean time for all that weird
very emotional just to come smack the
fan I would say is this Sunday if you
didn't remember you're welcome and if
you did remember
I'm sorry kind of bad way to intro this
let me a hey you know you win some you
lose them so every dad when their child
is born every year I spring the super
cake I kind of make a video in which I
give you some inspiration on creating
gifts for your father for Father's Day
and this year is no exception except
this is just basically a cooking video
that can be also packaged as a gift to
your dad cooking bread that's beer and
wieners in it it's exactly their mom got
pregnant honestly that's the only reason
that this video is happening for that
singular joke so worth it I see a ton of
recipes online and which you can make
bread with beer substituting the yeast
and if I can substitute any food for an
alcohol I'm going to do that also this
year for Father's Day and likes to my
dad or my stepdad that's watching this
video stop watching right now okay I
don't know how to use computer so you
won't be watching this video I got my
dad a beer of the Month Club yearly
subscription I got my stepdad a steak of
the Month Club yearly subscription so I
thought that I would combine those two
things in this potential Father's Day
meal it's big dad equivalent of an
edible arrangement we're making red with
beer and we're putting some wieners in
it I got to wash my hands and then take
your shot of tequila because alcohol
eliminates bacteria I'm using recipe
called quick beer bread from glittering
goulash calm it's basically what I
Pinterest fear bread recipe this is one
of the most popular ones that came up
I'm going to use this recipe as like a
foundation and then I'm going to modify
it a little bit and of how dads make
their children I'm going to make a child
but based on my persona
I'm going to modify the way it operates
from the world with others cool we have
two prettier oven to
degrees is the microphone on okay
because I really want you to listen to
me
does my impression my dad okay
generously grease a loaf pan we should
wash this is what every hair makeup team
says about me every time they have to do
my hair and makeup for an event hey now
I just generously grease this loaf pan
if there's anyone that knows anything
about a generous grease it's a girl from
New Jersey let's do this this is the way
my mom taught me how to grease any
baking pans when I was growing up you
take a paper towel and a bunch of butter
grease and then you just like smear it
in there we've generously greased we
should get STD check but hey every
Jersey girl knows that ignorance is Oh
whoever you Bowl we're going to add
three cups of flour
probably not clean if they stick
together when you pick up only one 1/4
cup of granulated sugar beautiful a
tablespoon of baking powder that's my
dad think I found like when I explain
anything YouTube related to a low along
a teaspoon of salt I'm just going to
eyeball it
now we whisk all of our dry ingredients
together in for ten then we need a half
stick of butter melted which doesn't
necessarily work because I decided to
try and go healthy and get Smart Balance
in a tub so it's done and stick form but
you know what wasn't sticks on your dad
people nothing like a second good you
look like vanilla ice cream don't do
this to me oh you're super melted okay
now we're going to add a forgotten
ingredients Joey
a 12 ounce bottle or can of beer kids
come in 12 ounces no one knows I'm using
Stella Artois why because it's on my
dad's favorite beers I'm too I like to
think that the name of this is actually
someone with a speech impediment saying
Taylor author which I am I have two
books available if you did not know just
some very casual but you know
intimidatingly wonderful self help guys
call Grace's guide the art obtained to
be a grown-up and graces style the art
obtaining you have it and oh my god
organic transition you can listen to
these amazing self-help books that I've
written I team up with audible all the
time as you know if you have watched my
videos for a while if you haven't you're
dead to me but hi
resurrected welcome back I hope you
continue to stay with us all involved is
an amazing website for audiobooks both
of my audiobooks are available on their
website as well as other books like I
can't make this up
: life lessons written and vocally
narrated by Kevin Hart Wow we all know
that the eyesight and good old dad is
getting bad audible.com slash grey and
he will be glad or mad but get your free
audio book for yourself or your father
with your free 30-day trial area
audible.com slash gray back to our
wiener bread let's do this you take a 12
ounce bottle of beer put it into our dry
ingredients and whisk it together
no dad would be so embarrassed no why
dad what's over okay
basketball my dad's back on board I just
want to make sure this isn't poison it's
not poison I mean it is poison okay this
goes in this is acting as our yeast in
our bread Chris you know for science
this seems incorrect so we just mix this
up how do we do this
oh we stir with a wooden spoon Oh metal
whisk is the opposite of a wooden spoon
this was a purposeful joke not an
accidental idiot moment when it would
stir this is the one stir until it's
just combined we don't want to over
combine it and you guys see that I'm a
cinematographer dad whoa this is
actually like maybe bread okay oh we
need to get our melted butter now
remember that friend we're have to melt
the butter into the greased loaf pan
boom boom then we add our batter okay so
if you're a little off it feels like
better and a soup of butter and we're
supposed to pour the other half of the
melted butter on top but hey we did it
bad choices are what led to all of us
being alive so Who am I to judge this
recipe right now and this beer bread
recipe says that we bake in the oven for
50 to 60 minutes but before we do that
this is where my modifications come in
and then I got a couple of wieners right
so put some hot wieners inside this
bread loaf so what your dad said this
Piermont I want them to be a surprise I
don't want to cut them putting them in
full side hmm
everyone thinks that they're going in
full-size Oh my brand deals are all gone
we're going to three now we're putting
our Weiner bread into the oven for 50 to
60 minute
again didn't plan this correctly but
your dad said when you get it wait all
my breads done low half finished so what
your mom says a night
it looks like red star loaf it looks
slightly golden brown but I feel like I
might need to put it in for longer the
other bread beer recipe that I read up
on but this aged cheddar cheese carry
gold on it so I'm gonna put some cheese
on top
what great dad doesn't have a layer of
cheese to him just smells great is what
no one ever said about their dad ever it
shreds us on top Oh does it be really
good and I'm really nervous about doing
well because I know I can't consistently
maintain that no daddy issues there I
love my dad honestly genuinely good but
maybe too much cheese on this we're
gonna put it back into the oven for a
few more minutes just to see a bit like
and I don't know I don't know I don't
let our bread rest okay
the loaf is not hot anymore but your
parents might save it before you find
out they're getting divorce
ha let's try wait what am i calling this
dad bread no meat loaf
no mere loaf the bread Weiner cuz dads
always want to be the breadwinner oh my
I might have made just one giant corn
dogs this looks incredible let's taste
it yeah everything's good about this
okay there's a little gummy which is not
an adjective your need for bread looks
really good you know you might have
needed to cook it more if you get tired
swallowing a I'm never going in a very
very elegant Father's Day snack we put
some wieners in the hot cheesy loaf and
you guys make this at home which I
encourage you to do let me know by
tagging me in photos on Instagram or on
Twitter and follow me on all my social
media platforms and subscribe to this
YouTube channel
turn on the notifications I make videos
Monday Wednesday and Friday now as you
know sometimes not
days only in something anyway
I don't know Dom enhance Wow no okay
this is why don't do thumbnails well God
dang it my dad refused to buy me Barbie
dolls growing up and I really wanted
Barbie dolls growing up because I was
raised with all brothers so just wanted
some sort of feminine energy so the only
Barbie doll my dad ever bought for me
with Native American Barbie and she was
beautiful but she was on a pedestal you
couldn't play with so she just had to
admire her from afar I think that's why
I'm the way I am today people can't get
close to me
hahahaha no one knows for sure the why
haha